afghanistan where the u.s withdrawal is
turning into a series of military
setbacks for afghan forces some troops
that the u.s supported
for nearly two decades are now
surrendering without firing a single
shot
right now taliban fighters are advancing
in northern areas where they used to
have
much less support and our charlie dagda
is in the capital city of kabul this
morning charlie good morning
good morning to you tony we got a pretty
bleak update from an afghan defense
official this morning he tells us the
taliban have taken over
rural areas in key districts to the
north but
they're holding off trying to invade
those city centers until
all u.s forces withdraw
heavy fighting has broken out across
northern provinces as
afghan government forces combined with
local militias to take on taliban
militants
across several fronts more than a
thousand
afghan soldiers abandoned their posts
and fled into neighboring tajikistan
in the words of tajik government
officials to save their own lives
taliban fighters have been taking over
bases like this one
in wardak province showing off vehicles
weapons and explosives they've seized
releasing propaganda videos showing
afghan soldiers under surrender
the surge in taliban violence has
accelerated since the u.s drawdown began
military officials won't confirm how
many american soldiers are left
citing security concerns but hundreds
may have to stay on in afghanistan
as a residual force to protect the u.s
embassy and the airport
the taliban has already warned that all
foreign forces
must be out of the country by the
september 11th deadline or they'll be
treated as invaders
and face the consequences
that afghan official tells us that the
us has pledged eight black hawk
helicopters by the end of the week more
than 20 by the end of the month they'll
be deployed to the areas
that have seen the heaviest fighting
jamie charlie dagetta and kabul thank
you